I'm thrilled that he's sitting right
here he's Jay Bilas good to see you sir
I was like begging you to come in studio
well let's get my picture taken and have
it have it on your Instagram account
anybody is anybody's on the Rich Eisen
show except me you have been on it but I
didn't know you were gonna be out here
and you said yeah I'll be here in Los
Angeles and yeah do you know how many
people will say look you're from this
area I'm in town I'll let you know
I don't they don't like literally 9 out
of 10 I'll let you know when I'm in town
then you find out you're in town I like
it yeah most people hey anything I can
do let me know
reach out let's stay in contact man you
know they don't have yours but you just
say okay sure
so that's like a Southern California Los
Angeles thing that I got used to how to
get used to when I first moved down here
yeah I'm like I'm gonna I'm not that guy
so when you said I'll do it I followed
up and now here you are that's the
equivalent of big fan like I was on a TV
show one time and and I was all
starstruck and I was total fanboy if so
the other people there and my wife was
with me and and we're in the green room
and Jake Gyllenhaal was on the same show
and so I went up saying okay well I'm
gonna introduce myself to Jake
Gyllenhaal okay so I went up and I said
hey Jake you know my name is Jay Bilas
and he goes oh yeah big fan he had no
idea who I was
and so now I'm telling I'm telling my
wife every time like somebody comes up
and I don't know who they are I'm just
gonna go yeah big fan big fan it's not
that you know here's a great thing to
say big fan here's another one for you
and I shouldn't you know what I
shouldn't give away some of the trade
secrets here I know Jays a friend but
there's so many people that will come up
to you and say you know Hank do you
remember that one time when we met or
whatever well you look great you know so
just like good to see you again
yeah good to see you again but I can
called out on that too like you know
when somebody comes out come on you know
no like I've said a nice to see again
you said well nice to meet you they go
we've never met before
okay I can't wait hello well good to see
him I'm a big fan good Jay Bilas here on
the Rich Eisen show so you first started
at ESPN a night
how did the SPN reach out to you I was
doing radio work I was a full-time
lawyer in Charlotte North Carolina so
practicing law and I started doing radio
games and somehow Dave Miller who was
was the you know the boss at the time of
college basketball called me and said
hey we got a game would you like to do
it it was the Big South Tournament
championship game and there was no bid
on the line because somebody had left
the conference so they lost their bid so
I did I did a game between UNC
Greensboro and Charleston Southern was
my first game who did you do I did it
with a guy named drew Goodman okay and
was a play-by-play person and we we had
a blast I mean it couldn't have been
more fun I was so excited to do the game
and and you know like apparently I
didn't soil myself so they offered me
more games the next year and it kind of
took off from there
were you a trial lawyer yeah yeah I was
a commercial litigator so I'd like to
try ladies and gentlemen of the jury
like you did that you every statement
closing statement well you know what TV
lawyer were you like the most that we
would know will you Matt we're more
Matlock with law and order were you
firing I was probably more law and order
type you know like the the one case that
I had that was somewhat gained some
notoriety was I represented a costume
manufacturer against Barney the purple
dinosaur so the group that owned the
rights to Barney went around and they
have to do this called Lions partnership
they were they were suing people who
were infringing upon the the image and
likeness of Barney and so if you don't
you know protect your rights you can
lose them so it just kind of happens
that way so I was representing a guy
named Philip Morris who owned two Morris
costumes and he described himself as the
Colonel Sanders of the costume industry
so and and you know he was a TV
personality and all that stuff way back
when and could have been a better guy I
really enjoyed but he had this they sold
this thing called Hillary the hippo
which looked exactly like Barney
and it was just being rented for people
to do you know parties for their kids
and all that so we wanted to settle the
case right away but they wouldn't settle
it because they wanted to make a they
wanted to make an example out of them
so we went to federal court and won no
case yeah we won and and we wanted then
it went to the the Fourth Circuit Court
of Appeals I had to argue about Barney
the purple dinosaur one step away from
the United States Supreme Court and we
wanted upset we will loss them so we
want some stuff on appeal awesome stuff
on appeal wound up settling the case but
it was the dumbest case you've ever seen
in your life and you know you go to law
school and you like to think well I've
learned something and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be a highfalutin lawyer and you're
arguing before a federal judge about
Barney the purple dinosaur it was
embarrassing so when you are
occasionally railing against the NCAA in
the way they conducts its business
that's not the first time you put the
system on trial J it is not when you're
when you have the the audacity to take
on Barney the purple diamond and the
worst part about it was my kids were
little at the time so they were Barney
all day and then there Bart Barney
Barney Barney and then I would go to
work and I'm surrounded by all this
Barney nonsense and in the funniest part
because the case is over I can say this
now yes I had I had had the costume the
evidence of the trial the costume at
home for some reason yes and my wife and
her friends used it to have a birthday
party for some of our kids for some of
the kids in the neighborhood and they
had all you know this back before cell
phone pictures knowledge pictures of all
this I'm like are you what are you doing
you realize this could end the trial
right here if the other side got ahold
of this she never made it to the Supreme
Court no no no no we wound up that that
never would have made it period but the
fact that it made it the Fourth Circuit
Court of Appeals would have loved it
just just hear Jay Bilas justice
rehnquist
eyes askew i subpoenaed Barney to the
trial subpoenaed Barney to the trial the
other side said you know your honor you
know we can't do that there are only
three of these costumes in existence
it's on the road doing this a hardship
of bringing it in and the costume is six
foot eight inches tall weighs like 250
pounds or whatever and I stood up I said
Your Honor I'm 6/8 and I weigh about 240
I got in there just fine
and so the judge ordered the costume and
they brought it they brought it opened
up this big truck and they wouldn't let
anybody see it unless somebody was in it
Barney pops out of the back of a truck
onto the loading dock the judge came
down all the the court reporter and
every employee of the Federal Building
was there to see it this is celebrity
right it was the dumbest thing you'd
ever seen in your life and and I just
did it because they were I just
subpoenaed it to jerk them around
because they were jerking us around I
figured okay we'll see what happened Jay
Bilas here on the Rich Eisen show
fantastic so what there's an interesting
documentary that I want to talk to you
about that you're you're gonna be a
front and center for ESPN films dies
it's a 30 for 30 it's something like
that the class that saved Coach K airs
on the opening night of the ACC Network
launched on August 22nd and it's your
recruiting class were you the recruiting
class that saved Coach K what is that
according to the documentary documentary
we are we were Coach K's first
everything so Johnny Dawkins who's now
the head coach at UCF right Marv calorie
David Henderson and myself and then bill
Jackman and Weldon Williams we were the
number one recruiting class in the
country we had we had six guys that were
all ranked in the top 50 and so my first
year there was Coach K's third and had a
losing he had a losing record and and
you know we were the one we were the
class that helped him turn it around and
we were his first ACC championship team
first number one ranked team first Final
Four team all that stuff and there's an
argument to be made we should have been
his first title team we lost a
Louisville in the title game after
winning 37 games that year so you know
we lost by a bucket and it was but it's
it's been interesting sort of going
through the process and kind of reliving
all that stuff
still long time so was Coach K in any
part of your recollection ever on the
hot seat oh yeah that's that was the
purpose of this he was he was like right
there to get fired there was a petition
circling around at the time to fire him
all the boosters were circulating a
petition to fire him
it sounds like Hoosiers yeah no it's
true they had everybody in the town
get-together Johnny Dawkins was Jimmy
Chitwood but but absolutely that was
happening and there was very there was a
great deal of concern among the players
that what I remember calling my dad and
saying what do I do if they fire him
like I'm not staying here no kidding and
my dad said will you just relax like
there's nothing you can do about it just
play you know you'll be fine and he said
like what are you gonna what are you
gonna do you know you guys gonna have a
town meeting there's nothing you can do
about it so quit worrying about it and
that was the right advice but but it was
a it was a great deal of concern and
then the following year my sophomore
year we got really good we were in the
top 15 in the country and one 20 some
games and got really good and then he
got signed to an extension in the middle
of the year or maybe it's early on the
year but that I remember like the wait
he's feeling this weight lifted off when
he was signed to an extension that we
didn't have to worry about that anymore
amazing what is it like because I know
you're a lead pipe wielding professional
Jay but what is it like walking into
Cameron into a game like say the one
that you did this year Obama's there
Duke UNC I mean it's the same as walking
in as I would imagine walking into
Fenway for a World Series game or
Wrigley Field or something like that but
it might playing st. Andrews or the
place has a certain meaning for you
personal yeah for me personally it's
it's it's maybe a little bit different
than everywhere else but you spent so
much time there both as a player and I
was an assistant coach there for a while
for three years so you know you know
every nook and cranny of the place it's
not when I'm doing a game there it's not
as emotional as other times I'm there
because you're there for a reason and
you know you're focused on something
else so I'm not I don't you know sit
there and and you know wax poetic about
the old days when I'm doing a game there
but oddly enough when it's most
interesting to me is when you walk in
there and there's nobody in there when
it's when it's completely empty and you
can you look around yeah yeah you don't
want to get you know goofy about it but
yeah you kind of do and there are two
places that I would crawl on my knees to
do a game or to attend a game or just to
be there
one is camera and the other is Allen
Fieldhouse of Kansas which is which I
have likened to I think Allen Fieldhouse
is the st. Andrews of college basketball
it's the it's a place where everything
started and those two places are are
there are other great places yeah but
those two are the best by far
Jay bill is here on the Rich Eisen show
so interesting you would say from your
experience where again they're
petitioning Coach K to be fired while
you're there you call your dad what
happens if he gets fired he tells you to
chill out from that perspective do you
think that kids if they're recruited by
a coach and the coach gets pounced the
kid should be able to be let out of his
or her letter of intent yes when I was
when I was in college I was actually a
member of an NC double-a committee
called the NC double-a long range
planning committee clearly we didn't do
a very good job but they you know I I'm
sure the NC double-a regrets letting me
behind the curtain to see how everything
worked because that's where I got that's
where I sort of formed this notion of
policy justification that we should be
able to justify every policy that we
have and I brought up in meetings that I
didn't think it was right that player
shouldn't be allowed to transfer and
when I was recruited lute Olson
recruited me to the University of Iowa I
came down to four guys that I wanted to
play for Coach K Jim Boeheim at Syracuse
lute Olson who was in Iowa at the time
and a gentleman named Ted Owens had just
turned 90 years old yesterday at Kansas
I say he tweeted yeah so those were the
four coaches I wanted to play for and
when Lou Dolson recruited me and lute
Olson is as good a guy as you've ever
met in your life but I went over to his
house he had the play that's how old I
am he had the plans for the Carver
Hawkeye arena on his kitchen table his
wife made breakfast for us plans for the
Carver Hawkeye arena and in a 10 a 10
year contract and he looked at me and
said I'm gonna be here your whole 4
years and he went to Arizona the next
year so if I'd gone to Iowa which I was
semi close to doing huh if I'd gone to
Iowa I'd be sitting there in a cornfield
and he'd be in Arizona and I'd have if I
wanted to go with him because I went
there for a Cohen to college for a coach
I wasn't going for a school I know Duke
done
to hear that but I went to play for
Coach K that's that was my choice as him
and so I thought that's not fair that's
not right
like the coaches get up and leave and
the players have to stay there or they
lose a year of their their lives why
like why do I have to be 23 years old in
college because of this you know I mean
I'm an amateur I'm a student to be
treated like any other student according
to NC double-a rules
I must I'm I'm I'm a student who just
happens to be an athlete and a student
to be treated like any other student no
other student is told they can't
transfer and participate in whatever
field of endeavor they want and I don't
see if you're an amateur why why do we
treat you like a professional with a
non-compete provision because that's
what it is
it's a non-compete provision and it is
nothing more and they used to say you
remember they used to call it they still
do they call it a year in residence
sitting out a year in residence well
that's nonsense
why don't you need a year in residence
when you go to college in the first
place right so after after being in
college why need time to acclimate
myself that doesn't make any sense
if you've already already in college I
don't need to acclimate to college I've
been there but yet you're a high school
kid going to college you don't need to
sit out and have a year in residence
then that that makes no sense so where
is the line cuz I mean Nick saving just
today at the SEC Media Day was talking
about the transfer portal being and the
rules being too liberal that that kids
make a four-year commitment to the
school you make the four-year commitment
to the kid and if somebody says I don't
like my playing situation or don't like
what's going on here I want out I'm in
the transfer portal and that should mean
I should get to go where I go where do
you draw the line well first of all I
love Saban I would love to play for that
guy if I played football he'd be he'd be
the guy I differ with him on this first
of all it's not a four-year commitment
it never has been the school doesn't
make a four-year commitment to a player
they can bounce the player anytime they
want but up until a few years ago you
couldn't make a four-year commitment it
was a one-year renewable you know a
scholarship was a one-year renewable it
was not a four-year commitment the the
the player signs the letter of intent
binds them to the school so
player was bound but the school wasn't
bound to the player yeah you can run a
player off anytime you want still can to
me it's a question of philosophy like
what what's gonna be the justification
behind any policy that we have in in
this regard and the the philosophy is
this is an amateur sports endeavor right
that's what the n-c-double-a tell it
tells us that this is part of your
education it's amateur sports well if
it's amateur how can this how can this
student-athlete the quote-unquote
student athlete be an asset to the
university because that's what the
coaches are saying that these players
are assets and they couch it by saying
well they made a commitment and they
shouldn't run off at the first sign of
adversity adversity like shut up
stop that like what Wyatt why don't the
coaches have to stick around you know
they get to better themselves whenever
they feel like it
so coach will take basketball for
example the coach at Cleveland State has
a great year goes to Michigan State or
where what whatever job is open they get
to better themselves right but a kid who
plays at Cleveland State has a you know
Bryn Forbes who is a Cleveland State
what he can't transfer and go to
Michigan State that is that so awful
that a player wants to better but but
people say well that's not fair to
Cleveland State they've invested in this
kid so they're saying they deserve a
return on that investment which means
the player is an asset it's pro this is
pro sports and you know I don't see why
it's so hard for people to really
acknowledge that it's professional
sports we sell it like pro sports the
coaches and administrators earn like pro
sports it's marketed like pro support
it's pro sports and and the only thing
ammeter about it are the players
everything else is completely and
totally professional let me ask you Jay
Bilas I mean if you're let's just say
there's an epiphany had at the
collegiate level and they reach out to
you to run it would you do it I would
yeah if if it were for real and I felt
like I could help this is public
information now so I feel like I can
share this but I was asked a few years
ago to serve on the committee on it
dance the release Committee on
Infractions somebody reported it it's
right so it's already out there I would
never have talked about this otherwise
the reason I was asked I'm not stupid
the reason I was asked is because that
would limit the amount I could comment
on on case I wouldn't be able to comment
anymore and so that was a smart move to
try to you know get me to do that well
you're a trial lawyer you see signed
through that but I it's also a conflict
of interest so I said I said no it's a
conflict right and and they said no
we've examined that we don't we don't
see it as conflict I don't care what
they've examined it's conflict I can't I
can't do that right so you know I said
no but if I were actually in a position
where I could help I would absolutely
help absolutely you know like I'm
serving on the competition committee now
which deal dancer plays competition
committee it deals just with the rules
of play so has nothing to do with policy
it's just the rules of play on your part
of people who said let's move the
3-point line
yes okay the rules committee made the
ultimate decision the competition
committee forwards the idea all the day
all of it we look at all the data and
then we forward on recommendations to
the Rules Committee
but if Mark Emmert just decided I'm gone
and then like hey let's just totally
change everything let's bring on Jay
Bilas you would say yes to that I think
I would yeah at this stage of my life I
probably would if I if I felt like there
was the authority and to actually do
something right and to end to help like
if because I do believe the system needs
help it doesn't mean I'm the only one
that you know has a good idea but but I
would I would more be more than happy to
help okay and in terms of that actually
happening that you would be offered this
opportunity what how warm would the
place to freeze over have to be oh do
you think that this actually is in the
realm of possibility with you because
your idea it's not the realm of
possibility there are I think there are
ideas that I have that a lot of people
within the structure agree with there
are but there are way too many people
who who are of the mind that wait a
minute now we just shut up just don't
talk about this stuff anymore like we've
got a we've got a line that we're using
quit doing that but you try to tell
people like look I'm not talking about
people like the the people at the
n-c-double-a are great they're great and
I don't just mean the the folks in
Indianapolis
in the instant of the office I'm talking
about at every NCAA institution like the
you'll hear all the time the incident is
the member schools so I'm when I say
n-c-double-a I'm talking about all the
schools not just the folks that work in
Indy right but there are wonderful
people but the policies need to be
discussed and so when you when you say
it's like talking about you know the the
speed limit or any law like it doesn't
mean I'm down on policymakers or I don't
like who's representing us but there's
something wrong with this law there's
something wrong with with the the rules
and and that's all I'm talking about but
there are too many people that think
wait a minute don't you shouldn't don't
say this don't talk about this but you
tried to tell them like look I'm not
suing the n-c-double-a I've never sued
the unsuitably other people are doing
that and these lawsuits keep coming and
they're winning now I don't think that
the n-c-double-a is gonna lose every
lawsuit that comes its way but they're
and they're not gonna win them all
either and you're seeing a lot of
movement like right now there there are
laws being pursued here in California
there's a law
there's a law being put forth on name
image and like this to allow college
athletes their name image and likeness
rights there's movement on that in
Washington in Congress so this train is
rolling down the tracks and in the
instant of ley is is seemingly wanting
to tie the players to the tracks while
the train rolls down it you know like
here in California with this name a
vision likeness law that's that's moving
forward you know Mark Emmert actually
sent a letter to to the government here
saying hey if you do this that like you
know you know it was like a threat
and and the lawmakers who took it as a
threat and and really said you're not
gonna threaten us we're moving down
moving forward anyway I saw yes Jay yeah
your Twitter feed starts every day with
you dropping rap lyrics when did that
start why did that start it started
about ten years ago give or take when we
were at Michigan State for college game
Bay and draymond Green was listening to
headphones we asked him what he was
listening to and he said Young Jeezy and
so Hubert Davis who was with us at the
time now he's an assistant coach at
North Carolina asked me do you have that
there's probably an iPod at the time
rather than a playlist or something you
have that on your iPod and I said I said
actually I do and and some you know some
people didn't believe it and so I
started going back and forth with some
folks on Twitter about it and dry you
know putting a rap lyric and say how
about this one or this one and and then
I wound up I couldn't do it anymore
because I literally had to go to work
and I think I said I got to go to work
or something and it sort of took off and
and and I started doing it every morning
and then and then I found out like okay
this is becoming a thing when I was out
on the west coast and I I wasn't gonna
get up at 3 o'clock to do that 3 o'clock
in the morning and I got a couple phone
calls later I going hey man you okay you
didn't put out your Jeezy lyric this
morning they're like man this is a
problem I got I got a problem here but
but it's been great it's been five got
to meet Young Jeezy and every once in a
while he shoots me at X and yeah yeah
I'm dropping an album can you put this
out or something it's kind of fun like
you put it out yeah like I'd put the
first thing out on it I've done that
once or twice your Twitter is your
Twitter following bigger than his I'm
like it I'm almost 2 million - it's not
probably not bigger in his but it's no
joke but it's helpful to I guess do you
still only follow one person though zero
he's at zero people follow it's a joke
when I first started on Twitter my wife
my wife says you need to get on Twitter
because everybody thinks you're some
geek that sits and watches film all day
and you have to show you actually have
somewhat of a personality and so I got
on there as a uses a joke machine and
but I didn't understand how mentions
worked or all that so somebody when I
figured that out somebody was like hey
you know who do you think you are do you
think you're better than everybody that
you follow nobody that's kind of good
yeah actually I do and that's like if
they don't let you follow yourself
what's the point and so I just kind of
do that as a joke how about you follow
just the Rich Eisen show from now on
just your one follow I could do that but
that would be I mean your egos out of
the
who asks that it's like asking a member
to Gustav hey can I come play you know
you just don't do that there's some
things that aren't done it's the Augusta
you just came back from Tahoe right yeah
how'd you do not great I hit the ball
fine but I just couldn't putt I must
have three putted 50 times would you
play with I played with Dell curry the
first day and he birdied the first three
holes hehe was on fire
alfonso ribeiro terrific he's very good
yeah very good and a lot of fun couldn't
been a nicer guy his brother-in-law
Brennan caddy forum we had a great time
and then Steve Young and Tim Brown
played with then I played with miles
teller and John O'Hurley so three three
fabulous actors played together and he
tells teller by the way that's great a
good dude blast John O'Hurley is a great
great guy and you know you don't want to
ask him hey if I make a putt could you
do like J Peterman for something you
don't want to do that I thought it was
fun you know I wanted a little bit of
decorum out there but it was really fun
that's great
let's hit the Wayback Machine a little
bit here when when Stewart would give
you grief about Duke didn't he what was
that like it was Duke you know yeah he's
a huge North Carolina guy obviously I
love talking about Stewart whenever I
can Stewart's the best and and you know
you guys were so great together but you
know every time like I was reminding you
like it was so much fun being around you
guys cuz you had fun right and when I
first started I was always worried about
making a mistake and you know so you're
maybe a little stiff and and you guys
relax yeah really quick because it was
there was nothing but we were all yeah
bill Pete oh you know every time you
turn around bill Peter would say
something that would make you make you
soil yourself yeah he was reminding me
we were going down memory lane Brockman
tell him what he called the ESPN news
set because ESPN news when it started
you know that's where people when they
first came to SportsCenter or ESPN they
started but then they would take some
established SportsCenter anchors and put
them on ESPN is telling it was encased
in glass and it had all the cameras were
automatic so they no camera people in
there so Peto called it the box
and you walk by and you say you say hey
Billy how you doing he goes how am i
doing I'm in a box that's how I'm doing
I'm in the box five years ago I'm doing
infl countdown now I'm in the box J they
put me in a box NHL to night Wednesday
box I worked with Billy doing doing raps
so bill pedo and I are doing raps which
is like kind of half times and he got a
shot sheet somebody handed him a shot
sheet which is what you read for a
highlight fair so he looks at the shot
sheet he couldn't identify a name so he
leans over to me and says JB how do you
pronounce this guy's name I looked at I
said yeh ghormeh Shirokov and then he
goes ain't happenin that's what you call
a career killer and then he called him
the big guy from GW on everything and
the big guy from GW did you you cross
paths with Kilbourne to annal or that
was Ross pass but didn't know yeah cuz
he left in 96 you got there and Danny 5
yeah and you do most of the games now
with Dan Schulman so most of the time
Sean McDonough so I get I have one guy
who's incredibly nice the other guy
yells at mean anything and nicest guy in
the world and he is that he's mr. game
day yeah does game day for a ball game -
basketball
and the draft - yeah NBA draft NFL
couldn't happen to a nicer he's the best
right I and and you know but I'm a
little tired of the hair I'm still hangs
on not only still has it but it's
perfect all the time nothing moves it
when did when did you realize that it
was going Jay in the early 90s I had
done a movie actually called I come in
peace with Dolph Lundgren come on where
I played an alien cop and they had to
shave my head so my hair never grew back
in the right way 1990 release gave it up
for Dolph I played an alien cop is a
fantastic movie my death scene in the
back of the car was Oscar worthy you
were good alien AZ yes I was I was the
good alien oh yeah nice to every thing I
aimed at I had this huge gun that fire
shot fire out of it I knew when you when
I'm like Jays coming on that it would be
great and it would be in
thought-provoking and it would be fun
but I had no idea would start with you
suing Barney and ending with you dying
for Dolph lon I didn't sue Barney Barney
sued us I was defending against Barney
the evil Barney and look thanks for
coming on thank you for having me big
fan for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on Direct TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app